[Music]
security health analytics is a native
scanner and security command center
it assesses the overall security state
and activity of your virtual machines
containers network storage and Identity
and Access Management policies the
built-in capabilities in the standard
edition includes scans for high severity
miss configurations such as open storage
buckets using the premium edition of
security health analytics you gain
access the scans for many more potential
security issues such as API keys that
need to be rotated in addition you get
compliance monitoring and security
posture management and standards and
frameworks such as PCI DSS CIS GCP 100
NIST 853 and ISO 27001 to enable
security health analytics you must have
the security center admin editor role in
cloud I am when you're finished adding
roles click Save then use the navigation
window to head to security command
center when you arrive click on add
security sources use the toggle to
enable security health analytics if it
is not already then scroll down and
click Save security health analytics
scans can take up to 12 hours to
complete on the first run after this
initial run it will scan your resources
twice daily the vulnerabilities
dashboard and security command center
displays the security health analytics
findings if we sort the findings to show
account of active findings with high
severity you can see categories such as
firewall rules that allow public access
scrolling a bit further we can see
additional categories for things like
cloud storage buckets that are publicly
accessible instances configured with
public IP addresses instances with SSL
not being enforced or resources where
the web UI isn't enabled for a full list
of vulnerabilities follow the link in
our documentation in the description
below drilling in you can filter and
view vulnerability findings in many
different ways like filtering to one or
more projects or by characteristics such
as category severity or applicable
benchmarks security health analytics can
automatically to
common vulnerabilities and
misconfigurations across a multitude of
GCP products and more categories are
continually being added after you filter
by the vulnerabilities that are
important to you you can click through
to view detailed information about the
findings
let's use the category filter to take a
look at the open firewall findings
drilling into a specific finding you can
see a short description of the issue
including the asset affected and what it
was detected by under attributes you can
see when the finding was most recently
seen and when it was first found and the
source URI the recommendation tells us
to complete two simple steps to resolve
this finding you can easily head to the
link which takes you to the resource to
fix the issue in a new tab all you need
to do is follow the recommendations and
click Save Here I am editing the
firewall rules to restrict the range of
source IPS that are allowed connection
to a specific projects virtual machines
congratulations you've enabled security
health analytics and learned how to
respond to its findings
[Applause]
[Music]